i suppose i've got to start with the
biggest announcement
of the year i'm leaving evernote it's
official oh okay
having a written down warm-up that you
do each time
makes such a difference in training it's
like
year 7 p.e level advice arm circles do
you do arm circles yes
i so i actually do arm circles hang on
hang on can i can we
start small we back up for a second are
you as an international level power
lifter
telling us that a game-changing life
hack for you
is doing a warm-up
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome back to the show it is another
life hacks episodes tools techniques and
tactics
for productive and efficient life i
tried to get some of the world's most
productive people on to join me today
but none of them are available then i
asked dominic cummings he wasn't
available
so i've settled for johnny and youssef
from propane fitness dot com welcome to
the show gentlemen
hello it's a pleasure what have you been
doing recently other than the first time
that we've been out for food
in a venue post pandemic
so far happened last night
not much well it feels like i'm doing a
lot but that's just like occasionally
leaving the house and going to places
which
feels like oh god like i can't handle
this novelty
my calendar's really straightened
novelty yeah it's
i'm enjoying it i'm enjoying like the
slow i'm pleased that there's like a
there's a road map of gradual release
because i think it would have just been
in your house for a year and then like
features of apple products
like you don't want the virtual reality
headset right now we want it yeah
to be drip fed to us that's a great way
of looking at it i don't think anyone
would be ready for like augmented
reality
so you need to phase it in don't you
fine yeah just push it back keep on
pushing it back by four weeks anyway uh
on this episode if you're not familiar
with life hacks we go through
whatever we've come up with to make life
a little bit more efficient and
effective over the last few
months since our last episode all the
links to everything that we talk about
if there's any discount codes or
whatever will be
in the show notes below and as is
tradition up first
is a hot potato for jonathan watson
there you go johnny
what have you what have you got for us
got it
uh i have a
an automation a phone an iphone
automation
uh as we were just talking about i just
have an old
cheap chatty iphone xr so i'm sure the
new ones can
do this automatically but one of the
automations i have set up
is to automatically turn on low power
mode
at a low battery percentage which just
gives me peace of mind
a little bit gives it a nice landing
strip doesn't it is that not
inbuilt already at 20 is there not an
option that pops up and says
battery is low do you want to turn the
low power mode i don't even get that i
don't get that it just it's already on
so when battery battery 20 when battery
hits 20
just turns on there's an automation that
runs that just turns on
low power mode so you've saved yourself
from this notification that i'm talking
about
because the notification happens quite a
lot doesn't it moderately
frequently yeah so how do you do it
where do you find the automation so it's
in you know the
there's like a shortcuts uh app inside
of your iphone
in there so if you have a just to play
around it's something that i've wanted
to like ask you both about whether you
have any of these
maybe there'll be some coming up today
but there's there's loads of stuff you
can do you can like custom
code things the most advanced i've got
is i have a shortcut to my inbox
i'm in omnifocus and i it turns on low
power mode but it's just
little things that you do all the time
that you can you can just make your
iphone do for you
i made one let's produce one i made one
that turned that blue light on
there behind the vertical bookcase in my
bedroom
and it's also hey siri uh
enabled so hey siri turn on the bedroom
light
that comes on big pimpin
is okay google turn on fire and ice
and all [ __ ] hell breaks loose in the
room
where he records his videos like
things descend from the ceiling this
small woman comes up then
consuela comes out of the floor and
makes sure that she swept everything and
cleared it away and then she
descends back into the basement
you've got to wonder why he's got a
google home thing though
yeah that was my first thought that kind
of weakens the whole thing
like it's cool but obviously i'm pretty
sure
it's okay google i'm pretty sure it is
yeah it is yeah
shortcuts are coming to mac in november
which is going to be big will it
because most shortcuts not already
enabled by
third-party applications alfredo
yes but so what what shortcuts for mac
is going to be is an overlay
of automator because automate is a bit
big and scary it's like
this terminal for the real navy seals
and then there's automator for like the
the infantry
and then there's shortcuts for the
president yes
okay cool so automatically turn on low
power mode and you go into shortcuts for
that yousef
the smith master what have you got for
us i suppose i've got to start with
the biggest announcement of the year
is that i'm leaving evernote it's
official
apple notes after all that
it was right under our noses this is
sort of slowly emerging smug face
as he's just talking yeah so
funnily enough apple notes over time has
just become more and more
robust stable fast and evernote
has managed i've never seen a software
company manage to actively kamikaze
themselves
[Laughter]
they were doing so well and the first
mover advantage
huge customer base really brought in uh
community and then they just pulled the
pin
they were like oh you know what would be
great if we just
nuke our building and just knock
everything yeah
just send all of our customers a poo in
the post yeah
okay so what they've done what are the
three things that have meant
made you leave evernote and what are the
three things that have made you uh go to
apple notes
speed so evernote used to be fast
external brain being able to quickly
access anything the command bar
and they got rid of the command bar and
they made it slower now those two things
alone
for something that's supposed to
function as an external brain
means it's no longer fit for purpose you
your brain cannot have a lag
even if it's only a five or a ten second
lag the mobile app can be up to 30
seconds
and that's it's not acceptable for
something so
even though there's a few features that
you might lose i think for the sake of
apple notes
with the alfred shortcuts so that it's
basically you can access a note from
anywhere
definitely worth it now there's a few
exciting things coming
to apple notes as well which is tags and
quick note
so you can just have like in the corner
of a screen
a kind of workingmemory.txt that cal
newport calls
it to just bung things in so if you're
in a
web page or whatever you can keyboard
shortcut just send it straight to that
quick note
and deal with it later something that
you can do now on iphone
is change one of the settings so that
you know when you swipe in from the top
the control center
there's a note button and you can ask it
to always open up the same one
and that can be your brain you're
connected yeah you're working memory
adding
yeah that's cool that's cool why why
not notion notion's good but it's not
really a
writing it's not really a writing app
it's more of a workspace like we use
notion with propane it's great for
collaboration
and tables and internal databases
and it's good for organizing like bits
of information content feed that kind of
thing
um but it's cloud-based it's not
you don't own your notes and so if
you're offline you can't access stuff
so yeah if if they introduce offline
mode
which they keep saying they won't but if
someone comes along and did that
i have to say so for the people that
aren't really into note-taking as i
really haven't ever been a i started on
evernote because you told me to and i
used it for a bit and
it was okay it was more power usery i
guess than apple notes
i've just checked here i have 1824
notes on apple notes um every uh set of
notes for a guest for an episode is on
there
all of the tracking for my adverts and
stuff are on there for the more power
based stuff it really is far too
unsophisticated because it's just a
really slimmed down word document
um but for the seamless stuff like
you're talking about and the brain
dumping stuff
it really is great that being said
synchronization as well between devices
seamless absolutely well i'll i'll be
outside in the garden or i'll go for a
walk listening to a guest
noting down some things i might want to
talk to them about and then i can be
finishing a note as i walk in the door
and see it pop up on the computer as i
walk toward it which is
it's [ __ ] hot right when this is the
advantage of going single architecture
single operating system apple across
everything
but you can seamlessly link your airpods
between different devices and switch
between the two and all the rest of it
um what do you use
johnny so it's interesting hearing you
talk about your
apple notes volume because when you have
told me this
i looked at my apple notes and i have
1529 notes
and i was saying this to yousef that
like i try to use
um so i try to use no i try to use
evernote yeah and i try to use notion
then i try to use craft um all on kind
of use as yusuf's evolved through this
journey
kind of people we're just lagging behind
him holding on to the coattails yeah
the premium productivity guy but but
when when i like need to write something
down
i just without even thinking about it i
open my open
apple notes and i just make a quick note
and then but why is that because
it's quick it's just like yeah there's
no lag
yeah so like i suppose with evernote
like you open it up and then you make a
note and then you've got to make sure
later on that like you put the note in
the right place and it feels for some
reason
like it's not this just free form thing
that you can put information into
whereas apple notes is just
it's literally just a list of notes yeah
it's just kind of what you need
now folders and stuff now and they've
made it they've made it better but the
original apple notes was like
literally just a list of blank documents
if they could
if they could have the main feature from
notion which is pages within pages so
hyperlinking notes within notes
and nesting them and organizing the
structure
of the um folder system in that way
that would that would be game over as
because that's the only thing that i'm
really missing
it's such a actually that and the toggle
function
you know to toggle down um those are the
two main
it's like to think about that it's not
exactly a power user feature but from a
user
uh interface perspective it's so space
efficient isn't it yeah like
have that accordion yeah and well i
suppose another one of people to check
out then if
if you want what chris just described
but you're kind of in between like not
wanting to do like rome research
or obsidian is have a look at something
called nota it's currently in beta
n-o-t-a dot md absolutely beautiful
like it's it's just amazing it's a
market down editor though so it won't
work as an external break because you
can't put
big files in this is but it if it's
purely for writing yeah and
yeah linking your id if you're just
doing writing what's the is it odyssey
not odyssey no there's another one um
the scrivener which a lot of people use
uh and what else yeah scrivener is one
of them
uh ulysses ulysses that's it yes so
those ones are for like
screen writing screenplays and novels
and that kind of thing
yeah interesting anyway my first one so
this is from my
uh speech coach miles and he identified
the fact that when you're singing happy
birthday for someone
everybody begins one octave higher than
they should do
and then when you get three quarters of
the way through the song and you need to
do the key change
you get nailed by that high note so
yeah exactly yeah so what you really
want to do is give it beans at the start
like happy birthday
to you like and then when it gets to
the happy birth you could just either
easy you've got it give yourself head
room
above the happy birthday song right
start one octave lower than you think
that you need to and you
and then if the kids aren't impressed
grab their face smash it into the cake
and go are you not entertained
fantastic especially the second part so
if you're
so you start off sounding like a bit of
a willy but
you have the last laugh because you hit
that high note
everyone else sounds like a 13 year old
trying to speak
well what people tend to do is just just
almost kind of
mouth that section yeah we'll just mine
it especially the men
yeah yeah you're left with kind of the
few strong people who can hit that note
but the the worry is if you're still
leading the pack and bellowing you might
be the only person singing
doesn't depends on how good does it
matter everyone's going to be like did
he start one octave lower
[ __ ] hell he must listen modern
wisdom life hacks
um yeah but there's always there's
always a couple of people i've always
noticed this when you're singing happy
birthday there's always a couple of
people
classically trained in theater and yeah
belting out some operatic
cello monster from the far side of the
room and you're like
just leave it to you yeah leave it to
you
anyway i really don't like singing happy
birthday to be honest what would you
do what's too long do you prefer for
he's a
jolly good fellow or hip hip hooray
hippy parents
just do away with the whole thing really
yeah
it's it's just a bit too long like just
awkwardly especially if you're
the one being sung too and you start
with the cake yeah
i think that's part of it i think part
of it is the
cringe fest awkwardness that you need to
endure
because if it was easy it wouldn't be a
sacrifice by anyone
it's the birthday bumps but the the pc
new version isn't there
the social with jazz hands yeah the the
slight
social awkwardness that everyone has to
endure that you're kind of like
seen as a bit miserable and grumpy if
you don't like smile and play along
[Music]
but it's his birthday yes it's
everyone's birthday once a year
right jonathan blobson what you got
jonathan
johann sebastian so
this this one i think you you might both
be well
yusuf won't be surprised about it
because i've already told them about it
i think you might be
surprised at it chris which is blinkist
okay we've technically technically
already featured this
three three years ago but i'm more
more than happy for you you know what
this is the messy middle
like he's gone from like
just just read book summaries to must
have fully architected the full thing
yeah
i've just read books i've got a reason
so the and i don't think it works for it
so what blinkist is for anybody who
doesn't know
it is a book summary service where they
and yousef has a better version that
they he'll heal juice in a second called
short form i think it's optimized
but they they summarize it into blinks
which is like it's like a 15-minute
audio of a book
um so the what i what was happening was
i had like 15 minutes in the morning
where
i would like want to listen to something
so i would try and like listen to
podcasts but it's like
not enough to get into most podcasts and
i would try listening to an audio book
but then you get the
like it was a cold wonderous morning in
1985
yeah you don't look like not really
getting anything in 15 minutes um
so i thought i tried it i'd do the trial
and it doesn't work for every book is
the problem
so like books that are incredibly deep
and complicated that can't really be
done justice in 15 minutes
i wouldn't advise it but if there's a
book that you like i've always fancied
reading perhaps that's a fair
most most like self-improvement books
are a single concept
that are padded out what are some good
examples of ones that you have
blinkisted
essentialism i re-listened to so this
was my test
so i wanted to see if i could get the
sort of the gist of essentialism
from the from the blinks and you more or
less can
i i think anyway um have you read the
full book to compare it to
most of the full book
not covered to cover but most of the
full book so
i it's a if you want to kind of pick up
concepts from popular books but you
don't want necessarily to commit to read
the whole thing
i think it's a pretty good service when
i originally go on
why not optimize dot me because i tried
both of these
three or four years ago and i compared
and i
came up with this the synopsis of
brian johnson does a better job of this
you think so
yeah i think so i feel like brian
johnson or all of his summaries
the same it's always like yeah and this
comes back to our fundies brush your
brain
yeah don't forget about me hi chick send
me high
so i think that's the reason why not
brian johnson okay
yeah just he's just a bit he's a bit
much isn't he
yeah maybe i mean given the fact that
not many people especially in the uk
know about him
what he is doing i'm aware he's got a
business underneath him but
optimized.me is a [ __ ] titan
does it still exist yeah yeah he's going
towards his
1 000 philosopher's notes he's getting
working working his way slowly toward
that isn't he which is just
ridiculous what's your preference then
seth
honestly i am still using i'm still just
doing full books
i've never been able to get and it's
more because
when you're listening to a book summary
by blinkist and so on i'm sure johnny
might disagree with this but
what you're getting is not the summary
of the book but you're getting
what the guy who works at blinkist deems
to be pertinent points of the book
and that might not overlap with what you
think are pertinent points of the book
now that might be good enough for you to
get the gist of it and then
say like okay that's that's a good idea
i think it's functioned as an advert for
me to read the full book
so if you're using it as like a tapas to
be like oh yeah actually i like that one
i'll go deeper into this and
then brilliant but i don't think you can
get the full time and attention
with a summary completely in sympathical
here
mate like it's if you if you like to
read books you get sent lots of
suggestions and you don't know what to
read that as a thin end of the wedge to
work out should i dedicate
the writing holiday talks about this he
reckons that the rest of his life
he's got about between 200 and 400 books
that he can read cover to cover left
that's how much
time he thinks he's got it's like some
particular figure and he goes when you
think about it like that you're like
okay am i going to dedicate one of those
to something that 300 pages in i'm going
to realize is total bollocks
um so yeah i i think it comes down to
like why
why are you reading the book and so i
think like
pick up the book and think why am i
reading the book like if it's a if it's
a book that you want to read because you
really like the author or you really
like the style of writing or you really
want to
sort of bury yourself in a concept
blinkist is not the right
strategy for that even if you want to
enact behavior change surely
because let's say essentialism right if
you listen to essentialism for 15
minutes
it's a very profound lifestyle change
to become an essentialist which i think
both me and youssef are
sort of converted to the church of greg
mckeown on this um so it's a good
example
to use because both of us are huge
evangelists of essentialism
to absorb that message which i agree it
is a book that has a single concept
do less of the trivial many do more of
the vital few focus on your highest
contribution
there it is that's the book but in order
to be able to take that insight
and feel the discomfort and hear the
stories and learn the examples
and think right this is something i'm
actually existentially bought into
i think you can only achieve that unless
you are
and you're not but unless you are
someone that is very easily swayed
like if you can be convinced of an
argument in 15 minutes for an entire
books concept
so much that you change your life around
it then maybe it works
well so i think that depends on the
strength of the concept so like i think
some of some of the most convincing
things i've ever heard
have not been like a five hour thing
have been like a sing even
like a quote for example like a snippet
of
stoicism you can read and you're like oh
[ __ ] sake that's right
yeah yeah yeah that's obvious that's it
and then you remember it and you can
sort of recite it and talk about it you
have to be in a receptive
mind state you have to have an empty
enough mind to hear that and be like ah
right it has to like have enough space
inside you for it to bounce around and
echo and be like
oh yeah i need to do this but certainly
for essentialism it was so
far i was so far down the bad habits of
being a non-essentialist that even
though it took me
maybe four months to read the book like
in
i remember days i was tracking a lot
longer than that but
it's still like that was just about long
enough to be able to fully digest it
really not because of the complexity but
just because of the like
you need it in bits so you can be like
ah yeah okay i need to do this and i
think
the way i look at it is like it's a it's
a it's a
it's a single concept that the reality
is just very hard to do
so like whether you spend 10 hours
reading the book or not like
you don't i don't think anyone's less
anyone's more effective at saying
no to things they ultimately normally do
because they spent the entire time
reading the book
but but anyway so like another example
might be like digital minimum
digital minimalism right like you
probably don't need to read
and you know i'm sure i'll get
criticized by all the huge fans of these
books but like
i know a lot of people and i'm one of
them who read the entire book
who still have a problem with that right
so like
i'm absolutely convinced by it i was
convinced by it ten minutes into the
book
i've got the concept of it but like did
i need to read the whole thing to get
the concept probably not
could i have got the same thing from the
summary probably so i think it
it there's a lot of books that kind of
fit into that category that are sort of
general self-development that are
generally a single concept and there's
hundreds of thousands of them and if you
want to read a lot of them and explore
these different ideas and like pick and
choose from a menu of things of like i
might want to try these five things to
improve
my day whatever i think it's quite a
digestible way of doing it but
it certainly seems to fit into your
daily routine as well
and this is a really important thing
that if you have a particular block of
time for an amount of time
like the reason that most podcasts aim
to be around about
an hour to an hour and 20 of the longer
ones
is that you can finish a podcast to and
from your commute within a day
the the optimal length and why a lot of
bbc world
service and all this stuff their
podcasts tend to be about half an hour
because they just want to get one
commute in
um so what you need to do is find media
types
that match the blocks within your day
with which you can consume the media
types
and as we've seen if you can just you
you don't do the audio book on the
morning because
you need a to pay an inertial price to
get over that momentum so that you
actually feel like you're enjoying it so
yeah man i'm hey if it works for you i'm
i'm all for it seth what you got
speaking of birthdays
this is just something you can do as a
target
for each birthday as you get older
to set some kind of like just some
something fun for yourself so that the
my example which is the most bro way to
do this is
bench press my body weight for my age
each year and so something that
i mean doesn't happen it could be like
say a physical target or whatever
that's associated with your age just to
keep you on your toes and be like
okay like as i get older i have to have
some measure of
of progress like obviously it would be
lovely to be benching like
75 kilos for 70 reps in
in 40 years but um i don't expect it's
going to be
achievable forever um but yeah just
having some kind of
target so that you're not just like
aging and crumbling away
what are the new things can you do that
uh i i didn't do it this year actually
it's a life hack that i don't adhere to
but you should try it
yeah because because the gyms were
closed so i don't know
didn't have a bench press mike your
housemate weighs similar to you you
could have just bench pressed him
could it just yeah true actually floor
press or press yeah
harder as well oh mike sorry it's my
birthday do you mind just uh
lying on me crossing your legs what
other ideas do you think you've got
other than bench press so
a bench press is a bit bro but you i
mean a squat very achievable
like for most people well into their 40s
you could squat your body weight for
that many reps um
you could run for that many minutes you
could
meditate for that many minutes um you
could write that many pages
or set it as like a a monthly habit
i like that uh i've got one that we have
all used
and all used together and i'm surprised
that no one's brought it up yet so i'm
glad that i've managed to take it
uh the aerobie pro disc which is
a type of frisbee i suppose if you it's
technically a disc
as i was uh corrected by my
coach a couple of weeks ago i sent him a
video of me and said i'm playing frisbee
on the field and he said that's not a
[ __ ] frisbee it's a disc
apparently americans take frisbee and
disc very seriously
but yet the aerobie pro it's the record
holder for the world's longest
uh disc throw uh which is insane this
guy launches it out of i think a
baseball stadium or something similar uh
and
yeah it's just having that or other
similar sort of
games that you can play with a couple of
mates or one mate slacklining was
another one
that i got into a couple of years ago
which is awesome uh aerobie pro i got
this same
aerobie um boomerang
that you can use um nerf
those sort of whistling nerf american
football things with the fins behind
them
just having that i think it's 11 pounds
or at 12 pounds and the amount of
sheer joy that even just us
have got let alone the times that we've
used it separately
ridiculous everyone should have
brilliant everyone should have one
there's a low learning curve like
slackline you can't just be like oh
let's just go out for a quick slack line
with beginners
they have to but airobi like anyone can
throw something and if they can't it's
great fodder to laugh at them with
yeah we looked the last time that i did
it with you youssef was
we're on a field near your house and it
was
saturday evening 6 p.m
peak uh david off cool water
and barbecue on the ground with cans of
red stripe time and
we just decided to find the longest
straight line in a two football field
long field
and started launching this thing
perfectly flat
really because we've practiced quite a
lot so we're quite nausey when it comes
to
throwing the disc and uh i'm sure
everyone else
thought that we looked like pricks but
to me
i felt like a king yeah felt like a king
you don't want to get it in kind of
bridge of the nose d if it's kind of
coming it because it's so flat you can't
really see it sometimes it disappears
for a second
yeah you have the most elegant
disc form johnny ever it just appears
yeah it's so
smooth man honestly it's like when you
watch johnny's amazing at bowling
are you really like is that not long
leave it
i think it helps there's a few things
like there's a few sort of niche things
like that where
so with with frisbee or disc there was a
field
in my first year of uni there was a huge
field next to it and we had a
we had a bear obi and we just spent
hours and hours
throwing it it's like i think anything
like that if you put a lot of time in
okay so another another example of that
guitar hero
no way are you good at guitar hero
that i didn't expect you to have expert
level guitar hero
can you do what is it through fire and
flame i'm just about to ask
oh really that's like the ultimate level
doesn't help i need to see this
so the difficulty with it is like i i
went into
game about two years ago and said you
still sell guitar hero
and the guy laughed at me
she stood it stood and laughed at me and
apparently it's like
this the most sought-after thing you
just can't get a hold of them they've
just stopped producing it
that's crazy wow well that's not that
because guitar here is another example
of like
friends round and it's just in the
corner and you can just have a go
and some people are naturally really
good and some people are talking yes a
nintendo wii
is probably kind of similar to that
right it's yeah
have you played table tennis on your
oculus rift
no i sold it i told you i sold it you
sold it apparently
so you can play table tennis and because
it's it's already quite a light
game anyway there's not much like
resistance it feels the most real
out of all the things you can do to
cross into reality do you improve your
real world table tennis tabling i reckon
there's there'll be a few skills that
you can port
quite well like probably surgery to some
extent as well
what i saw i saw during the build-up to
the logan paul floyd mayweather fight
that logan paul was preparing with a
virtual reality headset on and a pair of
vr gloves i don't know what that was you
know i have the
quest the cheap one quest part
quest bars an oculus quest they like
they brought out a really
like low priced one yeah not the one
that's a couple of grand it's like 200
quid
facebook make it i own one of those
okay so i've played i've played table
tennis on it
we need someone
someone said that um the next step is
that they take like a front and side
profile
photo of you and they can map it as your
face
and because it has eye tracking inside
it you could have
a chat with someone and be making eye
contact with them fully
digitally they've just
they've just added this feature to it
which is hand tracking so no you know
how there's normally the controllers
now you can just use your hands so you
can have front-facing cameras
yeah right so you can pinch and throw
and grab
and it completely tracks and the
weirdest thing about it is like
why it sometimes feels real as you do
that and
the hand responds how you would think
your hand responds and so i suppose
there's a
there's a moment where your brain thinks
like this is just reality
you've all seen that video of the guy
doing the climbing up the side of the
mountain in the middle of a game stop or
something
and he falls off that and crashes
straight through in the real world
crashes straight through the screen
because
his body tips him over thinking that
that's what's happened anyway buy
an aerobic pro disc everybody needs one
when we do
a life hacks on a sofa next i'll bring
the oculus and we'll film
remember exactly before a life hacks
where i made you guys watch
uh vr porn i do remember that i thought
it was a vr horror thing that you showed
us
i showed johnny the pawn okay unless
i was thinking like if you and i watched
the same thing useless version of horror
horror yeah right it's like a zombie
thing
johan what have you got what happened is
it me
is it not yourself no it's just me
what did he say birthdays is a benchmark
target
bench mark target what am i gonna say
i've got one um it's also a birthday
thing
and it was remind i was reminded of it
because
it was my birthday like a week ago and i
got an email
from myself on my birthday
that i wrote a year ago and the reason
that i wrote the email to myself a year
ago
was because of um how's it called
follow up then no
[Music]
happy birthday six minute diary oh yes
one of the like weekly challenges
so i had it on my to-do list for
literally months to like write this
email to myself and i was like oh yeah
i'll do that
like yeah it's the kabuki movement
systems of moving it to the next day
and i eventually did it and i got this
email from myself and it was just it was
bizarre
reading it have you did it can you get
can you give us an excerpt
it was like it was just sort of the way
that i wrote it was like what i was
doing at the moment so
i was speaking about so we just got into
lockdown in the uk or like we've been in
lockdown for a couple of months
and like i was talking about how like oh
i think it's going to be back open again
for
you know august and all sorts of stuff
and then things that were going well
talking about things that were just
happening in propane like we were just
about to hire alex stuff i was doing in
training
stuff that was hap like plans we had for
the rest of the year um
and then like stuff i wanted to achieve
that i've done all of which is
really cool and then like see you in a
year and i got this email and it was so
we you like read it you think
this is a scam or something this is
weird like oh no [ __ ] i wrote this
and yeah so it would really reflect i
did that for myself
a while ago it was a website that sends
you an email in in 10 years time
so so i did it at 18 and received it at
28.
and oh my god yeah i mean there's people
that do it with videos as well isn't
that have you seen like there's a viral
video of like a conversation with my 12
year old self
and they've set it up like a back and
forth conversation
that's cool yeah i am i've said for ages
it would be so fascinating to be able to
take snapshots of your consciousness
and then be able to revisit them because
the things that consume your mind
now and the things that consume your
mind two years from now are so
well they should be different if you're
making progress right you should be
casting
off the worries and the concerns and the
anxieties that no longer matter and you
should be focusing on the things that do
we all should be moving toward an
essentialist's life i guess in one for
both in terms of our thoughts and our
actions but yeah even just thinking
about okay
so what am i doing at the moment what
are my predictions for the rest of this
year and then
stress testing those or comparing them
against what actually happened that's
pretty cool
i think i did like what what am i doing
what what am i like
what's going well what's not going well
what am i worried about and what do i
what am i like working on
and the interesting thing was all the
worries like none of them happened
on a single one all of the things i was
working on i
got done and then like some of the
things that i was like clearly consumed
with
just don't even not even a feature
anymore so it is just this
reminder of like at the time that was
just my absolute my reality
like consumed a hundred percent of my
daily world yeah and now like so little
of it matters
so that i use as you just mentioned i
use something called follow-up then so
you send it it's a service where you
send an email to like
one year at followupland.com and it just
sends it back to you in a year or you
can set it a specific date or whatever
um but really easy thing to try um
i highly recommend giving it a go send
an email to yourself is it the number
one
yeah or is it o-n-e one number one year
at follow upland.com awesome
all right the date as well what you got
this
is from alice who is a a new
member of team propane and i feel like
she's going to beat me up if we don't
suggest this one
tesco own brand stuffing so
the reasoning behind this is that when
you're dieting
stuffing is a great kind of filler it's
pretty low calorie it's very flavoursome
very rich
with flavor so it hits the spot with all
of the like when you have like a savory
kind
of but
it's um it's very low calorie density
she said if you're out of
the tesco one then lidl is also
a pretty good substitute you have to be
in little to get that though don't you
you have to be in yeah that's how it
works yeah that's definitely how it
works
yeah so we were she was like i'm a bit
reticent to say this because if i
if i do and then everyone goes out and
buys it she'll
be struggling up against lower demand
i'm pretty
convinced that a good portion of the net
worth
of lindale's fog has been
directed from this podcast so tesco what
are the macros on it
pretty good um
so neither of us have tried it she only
recommended this to us like
a couple of days ago but she's a big
listener of the lifehack series
especially
but um i was saying that stuffing
is one of those things that i feel like
i
am never given enough of in a meal well
it's such a rarity to even have it right
how many times a year do you have
stuffing maybe
for me it's easily sub five yeah yeah
so and then and then whenever you do you
never look at a plate and go a bit much
stuffing on there yeah
it's [ __ ] oh man what is this
stuffing
it's really nice isn't it it's like i
really like one of my favorite bits but
there's never enough of it and it's
never something anyone talks about what
if you
what if by using it as a dietary aid you
spoil stuffing
well is that a price that you're willing
to pay is that really a price you're
willing to pay
i'm i'm quite keen to just get it out my
system once
and for all and just have a big bowl of
stuffing the remaining
the remainder of your life's quota
allowance
of stuffing in one see what it's like
because it's one of those things that
like
when you're a child you think well when
i'm when i'm older i'm going to be able
to make my own dietary decisions and if
i want enough stuffing i'm going to
bloody have enough stuff
i'm just going to wait for the
conversation johnny what are you eating
it's a bowl of stuffing leave me alone
i've been waiting for this for 15 years
just leave me alone my own man now uh
okay right this is a life hack that i
got that was submitted from craig
davison um he heard me talking about
youtube premium
on the last episode which everybody
should get everyone needs youtube
premium i am now
four five six months deep michaela
peterson told me to get it and
i do not regret it at all um
it is fantastic now the life hack
is that if you set your billing location
to argentina
you can get it on the last one i think
you can get a youtube premium
subscription for 94 pence i didn't say
it
um i might have told you about it
separately i might have messaged you
about
it um anyway it's a very crisp solution
well it's not a quick solution this is
this is a
the most used solution that i've ever
seen well no
mine's to bypass all that and just use
enough like a yeah a sensible person
okay so craig says
if you've got a vpn you need to get a
vpn you can go to surfshark.deals
modern wisdom and you need to set it to
argentina then when you get to the
payment
you add a random argentinian address but
include your uk postcode somewhere in
address line one
work for me with starling bank no
difference at all and you only need to
use the vpn as a one-off
94 pence a month youtube premium i can't
think of a better way to spend 94 pence
there we are okay silence as the crowd
is
stunned i just don't want to stir the
pot i feel like i'm fairly
like i'm fine with it like i'm not
changing i'm also not changing
but if the price if price was the
limiter if you said ah
12 13 pounds a month for youtube premium
yeah
it's a travel tavern if you said that
it's too much then
here is your here is your thin end of
the wedge
right johnny what you got uh
so i'll open with a question for both of
you which is
when you last trained
in the gym did you do a warm-up
very briefly
yes but that's a recent
thing as i'm starting to face my
mortality
interesting manual pause so that so
basically the life hack it's not i
suppose it's not really it there'll be
some people who listen like obviously
mate
but having like a prop like a written
down
thing that you do each time warm up
makes
such a difference in training and it's
the it's the first thing i skip
and it's like it's pro it's like year
seven pe
level advice arm circles do you do arm
circles yes so i actually do
arm circles hang on hang on can i can we
start small we back up for a second
hold on are you as an
international level power lifter telling
us
that a game-changing life hack for you
is doing a warm-up this is because the
power lifters
warm up is empty bar for three reps 60
kilos for
three reps 80 kilos for like no but
hundreds you just go up in 20 kilo
plates but maybe
a double and then you work straight it's
either that or spending like 45 minutes
doing all kinds of
like weird hip activation and then two
hours later you hit a first
work set so i think the only thing that
really matters is
just elevating body temperature like for
most people
did you listen to the episode i did with
dr sam spinelli about how to create the
perfect warm-up
so i actually think i did yeah yeah it
was quite a while ago
yeah awesome anyone that needs to design
their own just go back and listen to
that you can be within 10 minutes
up to speed with not tempted the podcast
yeah it's 50 minutes
podcast is longer than the warm-up but
designing it makes sense
what's yours walk us through yours
briefly uh
so i do a like empty bar
so i train in my garage so i don't have
any like cardio equipment or anything
like that so i do an empty bar like
barbell complex
of just like some basic movements for
sets of ten um
i do some light foam rolling
just to sort of feel a bit more bit less
a bit less tender but more supple
and then things like it depends what i'm
doing so i'll do like leg swings or like
some dynamic stretching for lower body
or upper body it only takes like five
ten minutes but
prior to touching the barbell i'm i've
i'm sweating apart from the complex
apart from the complex yeah that's not
it is technically my defense a different
barbell
so price is touching the main the the
barbell of the day
um it's a i'm sweating and i think
that's the key thing it's like i know it
sounds so
it's always speaking about last night
right about how you start off
doing simple things and you make
everything immensely complicated and
then you come back to just like
it might be a good idea to just sort of
get nice and warm prior to doing some
some strenuous exercise
but like especially if you train for any
kind of performance or you're doing
you know compound heavy lifts the
performance of the session is better the
injury risk of the session is lower
you generally just feel better but it's
the first thing
you skip and i very rarely see people
doing one consistently so unless you do
like a crossfit class or something where
it's part of built in
yeah right so if you said you said um
was it write it out or prescribe it
somewhere is it on a board somewhere in
the
so i actually have it in an apple notes
file
that's been turned into a checklist and
i don't know whether you've ever used
this but when you use a checklist
function on apple notes the thing that
the bottom gets grayed out and gets
shrinked to the top
so then the neck so basically just like
and then at the end i just don't check
them all right so i just have it on the
on the ground i'm on my phone press
through as i'm doing it and then that's
i just make sure i'm you never thought
about putting a white board up in your
i have yeah i have let's figure it out i
i quite like going
off phone whenever i'm doing programming
that's been written for me
constantly checking my phone doing stuff
just i appreciate for a power lifter
that's got all manner of
gizmos attached to the bar speed and
that's rpe
if i could show you the spreadsheet that
i have to navigate to just do a training
session
it's frankly ridiculous it's pushing the
limits of google sheets
yeah it resource limitations so to give
you some perspective it's so
big and vast this sheet that i will like
enter what i've done
and it takes five or six seconds bear in
mind this is cloud-based and google
it takes five or six seconds to
calculate what that means wow
so the idea of like just using a
whiteboard instead of that
might be a bit of a challenge for the
warm-up i could definitely do it for
sure
nice seth what you got i've stolen this
one from johnny
i don't know if we discussed it on the
last one
but the hack is if you're ever faced
with a
office box of krispy kreme donuts
don't piss about don't go for the the
plain
disc with the ring in the middle just go
for the
the nice one like the nutella or the
biscoff or whatever
because we looked at the calories and
they're not that different
between the plain boring one and the
all all singing dancing
flashing lights one
i'm going to throw a spanner in the
works oh no
i i prefer the original glazed
well that's fine if you prefer it then
then you know you because it's still
slightly lower calories
it's just not that much lower than but i
resent your implication that it is
of a lower caliber i resent your
implication that
pejoratively for most people they don't
want you the basic [ __ ]
ring thing that is not that everyone
can your preferences are not everyone's
like oh i like the
the vanilla emissions very problematic
for me however
the the real thing to avoid is the
mocker
because that is the mocker from krispy
kreme donuts
is similar calorie amount to
any of the donuts so just eat a doughnut
why does it taste it tastes bad well
i think it i'm sure it'll be all right
because it's very hard you've got
mouthing a doughnut that you've never
eaten
what what what's the reason to avoid the
marker because of the calories
oh the market drink not a mocker flavor
donut right thank you we are all on the
same page now
okay so your your argument is when
faced with a selection of krispy kreme
donuts the calories across the board
are fairly similar so just pick the one
flavor-wise that you're going to enjoy
the most and don't really concern
yourself with the calories
yeah because from a from a percentage
like from the from the
the amount extra it's it's still a
couple hundred calories a doughnut so
just enjoy yourself
don't try and pick a low calorie
doughnut because it's not gonna happen
i like it uh what am i going to do for
this one
so this would have been really perfect
if the government
hadn't decided to wreck everyone's
travel plans
um but i'm going to put this one in as
people may be getting ready to
a lot of people from america listening
um and
people getting ready to start traveling
around it's a double up
life hack the first one is
gate d2 in amsterdam airport
so amsterdam is a
commonly used connecting airport for
many flights going through europe and
further further on um they have designed
the entire airport
very well um but it's done in a manner
that makes it incredibly hard to sleep
if you can only sleep lying down
because everything has those uh jutting
up
bars in between that they're
masquerading as arm rests but actually
they're just to stop people from
sleeping
um however gate d2
in amsterdam airport is almost never
used
it's all in alcoves and they don't have
any arm rests on there
so you can go if you've got a three-hour
layover
often coming back from somewhere you've
arrived at 7am and you're waiting to get
to your next place at 10 a.m
you can go there set an alarm for a
couple of hours if you've got a face
mask and a pair of airpod pros
you're silent dark able to lie down
you're in a place that's so low traffic
that your possessions are probably
fairly safe
uh and you can stretch out there you go
gate d2 the other cool thing about that
is at gate t2 will just be a load of
modern wisdom listeners
so you can just speak it's like a real
life discord server yeah
i said there'd be loads of people
lying down with an eye asking airpod
pros and you'd be like
this is weird this is us these are my
people
none of them will want to talk to you
but you'll just know you'll be in good
company
i love that and the second part of this
was something that i did in
uh dubai last year which i can't believe
that i never did before
as soon as you arrive anywhere on
holiday
just go to the nearest supplement store
and buy a
small pot of protein
no one ever hits their protein target
when they're away
you're always just in between meals and
struggling to get stuff
by you know whatever nitraflex
or maximum mistake in uh new york i
bought muscle milk
and then it looks nice it sounds great
it's nice but it's
estrogen predominantly sugar it's
basically a weight gainer
with like a tickle of protein but it's
just
big what you really want is ideally like
a whey concentrate or an isolate or
something don't you
but it's easier than taking it out with
you because that's got all manner of
potential havoc to wreak inside of your
luggage you're getting stopped also
what's this uh what's this big bag of
powder that you've got here
um but yeah just go on holiday get
yourself a shaker buy
a what is it what's is it like two pound
or a one kilo
yeah half kilo's not going to be enough
one one kilo will get you through
that'll be like two shakes a day for a
week
not that you need that necessarily but
you'll hit your protein much more easily
it'll keep you satiated and you'll just
feel less guilty
so something that i was feeling grateful
for
the other day so i i went on like a
travel around the uk
and was in a similar situation where
like
you so short on protein you haven't had
much fiber and you think like i'd be
great have a couple of protein bars
that'll sort me out it does like ticks
both boxes
if i if you go back like to when we were
navigating supplements for the first
time
the thought of being able to get a
protein bar from like any wh smith you
you go past would just be unheard of
you'd have to get them from like
predator nutrition
or you know you know and it would only
be like predator was the only place that
had something
owned by a man with a face tattoo yes
exactly and they've got like shelves in
the back that are all just
pro hormones and then some quest bars
now you go into boots
and get like every grenade bar flavor
and
it's brilliant that that exists so i
used to
pack tubs of protein and take them with
me the fact that you can just get them
wherever you are now
brilliant brilliant johnny where you
going
is me um
so this is another this is similar to
blinkist
um but it is curio
have you heard it before nope no you
suffered because youssef was
you saw the curio product map two years
ago when it was about to be released
i mean you signed up for the i actually
think that you
enjoy pre-release products more than the
full release you're such an anticipatory
being aren't you
yeah it's just like like the the
greyhounds pulling at the
yeah that's alicia just want to try the
new thing you're one of the only people
i know who gets
actually excited about like apps being
released and updated
it's so sad but having having you as a
friend in our friend group is perfect
because we're never going to miss
anything because we were alerted about
it eight months before
when it got when it got leaked on apple
news dot io
like you were sweet okay so what's this
what's this curio thing
so curio is um
so the so so the first thing that
actually drew me to them was that their
instagram ads are really impressive
i think so they're like their angle is
really impressive which is
there's and you may have seen them
there's people going down an escalator
in like the london underground
and everything's in black and white
apart from one person who's listening to
something everyone's reading and this
one person's listening to something and
they're in bright vivid colors and the
angle is like be the most interesting
person in the room
i was like that's so cool caught my
attention clicked on it
so it's the same problem as blinkist
which is like i have a these windows of
time where i just want to listen to
something interesting
so curio takes like articles from you
can ask it where
where to pick them from so it's
basically what you guys do with pocket
where you're sort of self-sourcing the
information but it does that for you and
it's taking it from
like wherever you want to listen to
stuff like the economist financial times
like
stuff that honestly i would just never
read but i end up listening to
i listen to stuff about like ai or like
the labor market or like stuff that is
actually really interesting it's not all
just current affairs and news it's it's
like really detailed concepts and topics
that are just narrated by people and
it's a subscription
it is a subscription how much i think
it's like 40 pounds a year
that's not much isn't it no well not
when you consider that like
what you get for that i think it's
pretty good so curio sounds like an
audio equivalent of the browser which i
think i've mentioned to you guys before
now the browser is five articles per day
uh hosted on a sub stack but also
delivered to your inbox but also you can
get an rss reader and stuff like that
and they have the listener which is
five audio podcasts of some kind or
another
but the main thing i think that both me
and you are getting out of curio
and the browser is just stepping out of
our echo chambers
now what you realize as soon as you
start to listen or read stuff like this
it's curated by someone else
is how narrow your own vision of what
you are interested in is
you think i am so much more interested
in tons of stuff i'm
really going to enjoy all of this and i
listen to the same
six podcasters and read the same
whatever but the problem is
if you decide to venture into the this
new podcast worlds or new article world
or whatever
and you get the wrong article from that
or the wrong podcast you're like
that's not really for me so what you
need is someone to take the top
filtering of the best stuff
from the best channels and feed it to
you so yeah i think
i think you've i'm interested in curio
and if people prefer to read
the browser is [ __ ]
it's so it's the only reason that i have
things to talk about that aren't
already from my kind of world view
it's a very good point like you have to
have the curation because it's like you
know if you've got a friend who's like
oh i don't like prawns
when was the last time you had a prawn
uh ten years ago and you're like right
well
try one of these and then they try and
you're like oh actually no that wasn't a
very good one but then they've already
thought like
right all prawns are terrible yeah and
they've tied them all with the same
brush
well so you nailed it which with like
all of these
all of these publications have some
really interesting stuff in them
but none of us have like the time or the
patience or the inclination to sift and
because there's so much stuff that we
won't find interesting
yeah so if there's a service that just
does that for you and it's constantly
varied and it's from different places
so like there was an article i listened
to this morning about steve jobs and
some stuff he did at apple
and then there was one about ai and then
there was one about
how like bars and restaurants in the uk
is struggling to hire people because of
the way the labour market's changing
and it's like 50 minutes of time you're
like that was like really interesting
to open your world for you in a way that
you would have never been able to do
yourself
as well exactly yeah that's a that's a
really good one
i hope that the platform and stuff's
good um
right it is seth what you got this is
from
andrew robson who are you
arbitraging other people's life hacks
because you don't have any
i've got loads but we've got uh i my
previous one so
i just i don't know if you guys know
this but i have i split mine into
physical and digital
and so mine was digital very similar to
johnny's previous one i thought ah
physically we could do with the physical
one though so andrew robson
lovely man who we've worked with has
suggested he said i have a life hack for
people with dogs
thanks for that johnny um that i keep
meaning to send you
you can get lint rollers which you can
wash under the tap and reuse
they take 15 seconds to wash
so there's a there's a macro level hack
at a system level
that removes the need for that which is
that when you're picking the dog get one
that doesn't malt
when you get the dog don't they need to
be groomed
more frequently though correct so you've
jumped out of the frying pan and it just
depends what
which do you consider where do you want
your battle to be on the dog's back or
on your floor which would you rather be
well would you rather be like having to
hoover up hairs constantly for the
entirety of the dog's life or just have
this one batched thing
that happens once every six weeks um do
you know the brand of this
yusuf it'll be like pound shop
but what's it called it's called
washable lint roller or something
for dog hair cool okay yeah i'm i'm i'm
all for that have you seen um
i think it's shark the vacuum
manufacturing
have you got a shark hoover johnny
that's got the hair removal
no but i've seen i've seen what you're
referring to yeah yeah because
if if you've ever had a dyson stand-up
vacuum cleaner and hair or something's
got caught in it
the sound that occurs it it emanates a
noise
that is like what i imagine judgement
day will sound like it is
so painful
and it just so that was happening
upstairs i had to keep muting my mic
about 10 minutes ago because the
upstairs neighbors seem to be just like
i think they're deaf or something
they're just that
who are the ones that used to have sex
uh it's the same flat but
they've rotated people they've gone from
sex to loud hoovering with lots of
hair wasn't there a person who kept
deferring their
alarm by a couple of minutes every
morning as well
yeah she would set the alarm for 5 a.m
and then snooze it every 10 minutes for
two hours
oh my god and just because she must
enjoy
snoozing or something so i um she
knocked on the door
because i had a parcel for her and i was
like oh by the way you know you're alexa
do you mind just so what happened was um
every night you just hear like a mumble
and then an alarm is set for 5 am an
alarm is set for 5 10 am an alarm is set
for 5 20 am
all the way up to 7 am what did she say
when you asked her to
stop being such a prick looked a bit
surprised
well because you've like she'll feel
seen and exposed because it's like
probably her little habit that
you know a solution to this would be
seth it would probably maybe cost
someone will be able to tell us in the
comments but i reckon it would cost less
than 1500 pounds
and i think that you would be able to um
extend the cord of your lamp put a layer
of sound insulation in
put another board in and then put a
slightly lower ceiling in
with more with the same plastering over
and then put your light back in and i
reckon for 1500 quid you could
depending on how much sound from above
you contributes to
your life's uh misery i reckon you could
get rid of it for
probably about a grand but as in
soundproof my ceiling yes not not ask
her to soundproof her floor
alternatively it's the same thing yeah
one in the same
you could also just get some great
earplugs or ipod pros
i get like you know shotgun shooting ear
defenders
and then be out like a light the the
more annoying things when you're
podcasting to be honest
because that just immortalizes it heard
anything
but it's because i've been tagged
right as as is tradition toward the end
of a life hacks episode
stuff that we have been either reading
or watching
on netflix and such and i am going to
open up with
marcella
what do you think it's all right oh come
on
oh come on have you seen all of it have
you seen all of the seasons yeah right
up to the irish
season really really peter's out towards
the end doesn't it yeah okay so it lags
a little bit but i just strong opening
yeah it was it was different uh it's a
sort of a
like an edgy line of duty less about
the actual storylines and more about the
main character who is going through some
dissociative psychotic
breaks and you kind of see this get
worse and then
the end of season two is probably one of
the
biggest twists in a story that i've seen
in quite a while i just thought it was
quite compelling it's on
itv uh which annoyingly unless you
upgrade for three pounds 99 a month on
itv hub
has inbuilt hard-coded adverts on tv
that you can't get past however they
have a seven
day itv hub pro free trial no obligation
so if you register in the czech republic
to somewhere in russia and you can get
it they can never catch you
but you can just if you want to pound
through three seasons of marcella
you can do it uh within the window of
time
of that but yes that's my first one
johnny what you've been watching or
reading or
youtube video in recently um
time on bbc with sean bean
and stephen graham blasted
blasted you busted i love it you've seen
that mega mix that super cut of all the
time
that sean bean said bastard
what's that show that he was in for
millions of seasons not tinker totally
soldier spy it was it like the
napoleon bonaparte [ __ ] where it's from
oh
god anyway that thing
um and a single word highlander
or something like that frontier
no sharp yes thank you
yes looks like it should have been
cold-hearted should have called it
highlander uh but anyway there's a
supercut of him saying
blasted all the all the different times
he does it anyway time
so he has he has his like i think it's
what his natural accent is like excuse
me
mate he's brilliant nailed it
so it's a very um well i mean i don't
know
i've not been to prison so i can't but i
imagine
it's a very uh quite so
i'll normally watch things in the
evening and like to wind down before i
go to bed
this actually kept me up because it's so
like
intense yeah i think it's anti-advert
isn't it yeah
well i mean we we did a podcast with a
doctor who had just come out of prison
after two years and his description was
he said so i've listened to that he
sounded fairly relaxed about the whole
thing
i thought yeah i mean he got day leave
to go and do it masters yeah you know
that helps
do you think sean bean should have just
asked to be trying to do it
[Laughter]
right time what's it on i play
bbc cool i like it seth there you go
the mortal kombat movie 2021
you described this last night over
dinner
as the sort of movie that six-year-old
you would have designed
the time the the ten-year-old
ten-year-old okay ten-year-old me like
it
the yeah the plot was written by a year
nine so 13 year old
but it's it's you for anyone born
around 1990 it was
a cultural phenomenon and so
to see it realized in that with very
good production value and
it's brilliant it's it's very much like
satisfying in the child it's not the
kind of thing to take your girlfriend
to i think i think definitely would not
be very popular
but it's what it is is the contrast so
they
because they did a they did a film
back in 1993 or something
and at the time i remember watching it
and being like whoa this is really scary
really graphic and
you've got like scorpion takes off his
mask and he's like a flaming skull
and looking back it's actually a bit
naught like it's all like you know
clearly a polystyrene
that's been dipped in petrol and sat on
fire and things
but when you see the contrast against
the current film it's like oh
this is good there's lots of like silly
little quips
and the occasional gratuitous like
someone
reaches into someone's into this like
big reptile's heart and pulls it out and
then
says like fatality and all that stuff so
there's some cheese
kind of fourth wall breaking i mean
you're watching a mortal kombat movie
it's a movie based on a video game
that was cheesy it was always going to
be that that's hey if you if you reckon
it's good
i've just gone back and looked at what
we suggested on the last
life hacks did both of you watch three
identical strangers
no did you not but you did you said i
did yeah what did you think do you enjoy
it
fantastic like re you come away with a
real
sadness about it yeah it's quite
melancholy yeah humanity's like
level of cruelty mm-hmm i think it
johnny it's the i
don't want to support you so i've just
realized why i've not watched it
and it's quite well it's not
embarrassing but stupid
it's in my to read list yeah well
you see struggle with that i imagine
apple notes yeah it's going to be
difficult
it's now on the correct list cool no one
needs to worry
my next one is gangs of london i think
uh both me and johnny have watched this
film or a series series it's
brilliant very shitty it's probably the
best series i've watched this yet it's
probably better than the most recent
season of line of duty which ended like
a damp squib
um i i think it might be the best series
ever it's
really good it's an hour long each
episode
for six or seven episodes um it's huge
budget each
individual episode looks like a movie
it's got
full star-studded cast including some
new people that you won't be familiar
with couple of guys out of peaky
blinders
it actually the first episode
watches like a guy ritchie film you know
where they're fighting in the bar
and it's all all right mate you [ __ ]
you want some do you
like it's all kind of real cockney
gangster [ __ ]
um and it just everything gets wrecked
and it's so good it's so
[ __ ] good hbo
i think hbo yeah so it's no sky atlantic
sky atlantic
yeah so anywhere you can watch sky
atlantic yeah now tv or whatever
has it i i was
superbly impressed how do you guys
manage to span
multiple networks i feel like it's hard
enough just trying to navigate like
suggestions one same as this so what so
word of mouth and then you go i'm gonna
get a subscription to these different
things
oh no no so i have um
i have a completely legal um
of course a management to my fire my
amazon fire stick
um which through using a vpn
is again completely legal via argentina
um but gives me access to a a few more
a few more channels and movies and stuff
than than might usually be
typical but the way that it works you
can favorite
different movies on that stick to a
central home screen
and both my housemates are quite big
into films and movies
so we all whenever someone suggests
something to us we just
favorite it and put it in there and then
it means that we all have a pool of
stuff
to watch that's brilliant yeah so we're
just crowdsourcing
we're crowd we're three degrees of
separation away from whatever a thousand
degrees of separation each
of different things and um one of one of
my housemates is
super into movies and and series and
stuff and there's always something good
in there
always and uh gangs of london was was
one of them oh
what's that what's the guy that's just
been cancelled for um
not not kano who's the guy that
no clock yes no clark um
the what was it called viewpoint yeah
yeah
that was that's really good that was
really good but didn't they not
publish the final episode because it's
available on
itv player but it never got aired on tv
right okay so i can go on to itv player
and watch the episode
yeah that was good until you started
touching all the cast wasn't it
yeah it's interesting that you said not
kano
because if you google him there's loads
of articles about how they
constantly get mistaken for one another
i think they're in a film together i
think they look
fairly similar similar ages similar
builds they're always playing the same
characters that's it like they're in
they're in similar films
similar series playing a similar kind of
role except one raps and the other one
touches people
yeah i mean i don't know who either of
them are but it's not
it's not ideal to be mistaken for
a professional toucher if you're a
professional rapper
johnny anything else any other ones that
you've watched i don't know whether
we've i don't know whether we've
mentioned this one before it's a film
um called knives out
you've seen it before um
so it's a bit like it's a it's almost
like a
it's a it's a bit light-hearted it's
like a game of cluedo but a real
it's like a it it's really hard to
describe how
what sort of film it is because it isn't
like a true story and it isn't
completely serious
it's based it's like a cluedo whodunit
situation daniel craig's in it and he
does a texas accent in it
which initially is like what the hell
are you doing mate but then you st then
you
the daniel craig is fantastic in it lots
of very famous actors
um it did really well it got lots of uh
recognition
but it's called knives out i would
highly recommend where's that one
it's a film so like i'm sure it i mean i
watched it like
a year ago so i think it'll be on prime
or netflix or something like that
i have been watching a seminar by a guy
called michael raduga
about so he calls it the phase
and it's if you've heard of
lucid dreaming or astral projection or
out-of-body experience is it
it's basically all of these like
hypnagogic semi-sleep states
that he just calls the phase and it's
fascinating the phase did you say yeah
it's
yeah it sounds like a pasta yeah
linguine
[Laughter]
um is this on youtube yeah
i actually used to work in a pasta
factory when i was younger but i got
fired because i made a few silly
mistakes
this is a joke
what did you do i'm not oh few silly
oh oh
one of the pharmacists came and said
that to me when i was like
mid i think i was like mid-cannulating
someone or something and i was like oh
yeah okay
and then like 10 minutes later you're
like uh right yeah anyway [ __ ]
but yeah so so it's
well it's basically a walk through of
how to achieve
these um state where your body goes to
sleep your mind stays awake
and you're able to navigate the inside
of your mind
in a very like spatial way which is
pretty cool
have you been able to replicate this no
i've been
i've only been doing it for like two
days it takes like months of practice
but um it's a very systematic method to
doing it so if anyone's interested in
exploring that that world that's very
practical
one lucid dream before they're like well
i suppose you have to remember them
don't you otherwise that it's not a
lucid dream
but yeah i had one lucid dream before
which and then as soon as you like
realize what's happening it
jolts you out of this yeah there's lots
of practices to not get like excited
being like oh yes i'm in the
then you're like pulled back to your
body yeah
that's funny uh jed mckenna i told both
of you guys about this over dinner last
night
uh i got introduced to his book through
jim o'shaughnessy when he came on the
podcast and i get tons of book
recommendations but for some reason this
one stuck with me and i'm really glad
that it did
he is a enlightened
mystic i suppose technically although he
hates the term mystic
and he's written a series of three books
just about his experience as someone
that's enlightened
now you think well how many other people
claim to be enlightened you've got books
from the buddha and so on and so forth
but jed mckenna is an alias and he's
never revealed who he truly is
so you would say well why would someone
claim to be enlightened
if they're only using an alias if
they're not going to then repay
themselves with the brand equity to a
personal brand by being the person that
is enlightened
and upon reading it it's basically a 50
a journal 50 reflection on his journey
to get to where he is
but he often just talks about discourses
that he's had he's just sat down with
someone and
he he was waiting at a coffee shop and
this 17 year old girl came over
and started jibbing him for being the
person that's supposed to be enlightened
and then they end up going on a bike
ride and he talks about this experience
but he's
very much no bs there's some swearing
throughout the book
and i've never read something that's
made me
so convinced through two-dimensional a
two-dimensional form
that is plain words on a screen that
don't move that somebody is enlightened
like the clarity that he writes with is
outrageous and it is three books and
they all have the same
cover and they all have the same like
[ __ ]
windows 98 clip art
photo of a border collie on the front
it's almost purposefully as if it's
written to put people off from reading
it that don't know what it is
and i'm excited to read this i wonder if
that's part of it man it's
awesome you can't get it on audible
doesn't exist on audible you didn't get
anyone to do an audio book for it
um there's no videos of him on the
internet there's some
amateur done home narrations of the book
over kind of nice images i guess but
that's
as far as you get well luckily i'm i'm
gonna listen to it using
speech central little bonus life hack
there it's a free app
for iphone that turns any pdf
into a like scrubbable audiobook
speech central yeah but you have to use
the pdf you can't just use it natively
whilst browsing the internet or whatever
which is like speechify
yeah it's not like it's done for like a
library so pdfs or
um and you can say you can export it as
like a mp3 as well
and it reads the pdf yeah you can even
take photos of books
so like scan things and little
bit what are the voices like the voice
is any good just like the apple
siri ones okay that's speechify thing i
haven't tried it yet but i know
that he's friends with ali the dude that
owns it and there
those guys seem to be really working
hard to try and get
whatever you call robotic voices as
naturalistic as possible
i think that's that technology is going
to boom over the next two years i don't
get how you can do deep fakes of someone
and yet text-to-speech is
still a little bit rubbish yeah yeah
it's true i don't know it's probably
running ahead of
what's commercially available maybe
that's what the iphone 13's
holding back to have something to to
give us all
to just take phone calls for you
lovely that's just our dreams
like the google the google ai assistant
like in a hair salon and answering the
phone and dealing with
inquiries that is incredible that yeah
well you can say google please book a
haircut for me at two o'clock on tuesday
oh no this is the reverse
like the google assistant it like works
in the salon and answers the phone
and like someone says like oh we've got
any availability on thursday and it like
works google being your customer support
basically
yeah i think did they not test it to see
if people could tell whether it was a
real person or not and no one could tell
i've seen a video of it uh yeah
yeah learn to code addresses get on
get on python and see c plus plus you're
gonna have to learn the code
i think this is one of google's like
black ops operations where
yeah there's like a yeah it's a search
engine but we also have like 10
companies underneath us that are just
developing all these
pretty worrying bits of software oh
here's another one actually i don't know
how anyone can access this because it's
on my completely legal and
totally vpn secured stick but it's
called next
uh and i want to say it's on abc or nbc
in america
and it is about a
misaligned super-intelligent artificial
general intelligence that gets released
out into the world
and they then have to try and control it
but it's completely factually accurate
in terms of the different ways that the
architecture would need to be
constructed so it's someone that's read
super intelligence by nick bostrom and
the boston must have like consulted for
it yeah well either that or they've read
the book because they talk about
recursive
uh self-improvement they talk about
intelligence explosions they talk about
uh whole brain emulation um it's on this
server it's trying to get out it's
manipulating [ __ ]
like it's very dramatized obviously and
it's like it kills this guy's father in
front of him and all this stuff happens
but it's it's a pretty good watch
especially if you're into existential
risk it's basically like
x-risk dramatized it's pretty cool it's
it's funny i was talking to ben the
other day who says that like
90 of his head space at the moment is
consumed by
the singularity and the existential risk
and i was like
ben like 90 of my headspace is consumed
by like the note-taking app singularity
like when that's all when they're all
gonna converge
someone i didn't answer this question on
the q a uh but someone asked
how do you not become black-pilled when
you're learning about so much
existential risk like how do you not
just go
full nihilism and it is a good question
i think
i think my nihilism is defeated only by
my sort of laissez-faire approach to
life
generally that my um laziness is the
is the antidote to that um but yeah the
p i totally get why people go to
the future of humanity institute and
completely dedicate their entire lives
to trying to solve these problems
so that i think that's my question with
it is like when does that happen
you know what i mean like threshold that
you cross yeah you get so
you the more you read about it the more
you learn about it you're like okay this
is a problem
oh [ __ ] this is really a big problem
when do you just drop everything
and go and like go and get in the first
trench and try and help out
i mean none of us are working on the
single biggest most important problem
that we have in our lives at all times
you know we we get distracted by things
that are of lower priority i think you
actually need to be
a very sort of unique and single-minded
type of person to even take that kind of
an approach
um it's a very like selfless thing isn't
it to say
i'm going to pursue something that like
has no immediate financial gain for me
or
[ __ ] it's just all about the future
of humanity yeah look at the effective
altruism movement
like look at the people that are doing
ea properly like rob woodland from 80
000 hours
like he is spending his life trying to
work out the best way to get other
people to spend
their lives in service to work and if
they can't do it in service to work
he's working out what's the best way for
people to give some of their wage
every single year toward the most
effective altruistic
um donations that they that you can like
he is
uh like orders of magnitude above
being selfless he's being selfless for
being selfless for people being selfless
is the thing that jordan peterson said
on your interview with him
where it's something like you know
whatever you find yourself being
interested in
that's the thing you should just
absolutely double down on and then as
long as we have a broader
broader spectrum of people with
interests like most things are covered
so you end up i can't someone was saying
like someone had been
researching influenza viruses and like
had loads of research about covert when
it happened because it just was
something that
he was interested in was that one of you
two no but it doesn't it totally doesn't
surprise me
you end up with these like really niche
situations because it's just someone's
passion and they just decide to devote
their entire life to it and as a result
we end up with this spread of things so
there's also
the counter argument of like if
everybody just did that
then there's a lot of things that
suddenly get dropped and a lot of a lot
of life just sort of ceases to function
anyway
we need the the way that it works is
there's a normal distribution for a
reason right the fattest part
of the distribution tends to be in the
middle on the things that people
converge on
um and this is the topic of my ted talk
right like it's your duty to give the
world what the universe
what only you can give it because only
you can and that's how we maximize human
potential civilizationally
um but you are right as well that
as people get more and more
opportunities to do something if someone
just becomes like a
professional whatsits eater you know
just dissecting the
minutia of how to eat a what's it in the
most optimal way you think well that's
probably a bit of a waste of a life
but if you have to pay that price you
have to have the watson eater for the
influenza
specialist then i don't know maybe like
people you know things still need to
happen don't they like
yeah so like if not everybody can just
optimize like that
because then unless some people are
really interested in like
you know driving a bus or you know and
that's their absolute passion and things
still run fine
robots it's been it's been quite a quite
detail
uh anyway i think we're probably about
there we'll leave it there what's been
happening in propane world is there
anything new for people that want to
become online coaches to know about with
you guys
there's a the the link the training that
we always
promote has been updated cool talk is
now even better
it's just more it's just more complete
so like the more people we work with the
more
like stuff we test we're always like hey
we did this and it worked with this many
people so
we added into the training so the free
the kind of module that we give away
the reason we give it away is like
people who don't want to work with us or
the people who can't afford to work with
us it's like
well this is everything you need to have
like a decent crack in it yourself if
you try and you get stuck
press that button and speak to us
otherwise there you go
so that's just being updated same link
which is
i think you know it chris well there's
two is it propane fitness.com slash
modern wisdom is that one yeah
that's the main one cool well and it's
much more gooder
than it was better than it was but
yeah better and gooder both i like it uh
so yes if you're an online coach
or a pt offline coach that's looking to
transition online or just increase your
revenue
that's the place to go
propanefitness.com
modern wisdom gents until next time
maybe it'll be on my couch i don't know
yes if i i think it will be legally
permitted
um and what was the last one we did on
the couch
got the sienna day one no we would have
done some life hacks once since then
since i think yeah it might have been
the christmas one
um that we did just before february
unless we slotted one in between then
and
and the the february march shut down i
don't know
anyway ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls thank you very much for tuning in
propanefitness.com modern wisdom if you
want to go and check out what the boys
do
and if you need any of the links for
what we've gone through today in terms
of life hacks
they're in the show notes below feel
free to submit your life hacks in the
comments as well or
send them to someone probably not me but
send them to someone and they might
appear on this podcast somehow
gentlemen okay thanks bye okay thanks
bye
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few months
and don't forget to subscribe makes me
very happy indeed
peace